هذا واعرب بيان للاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلق
بالغ ازاءه زايد العنف في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله ودعاء البيان القاده
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين الى تهدئه
الموقف والامتناع عن الاجراءات التي تزيد
مستوى التوتر المرتفع بالفعل الاتحاد
الاوروبي ايضا ان المستوطنات غير قانونيه
بموجب القانون الدولي وقال انه يجب على
اسرائيل وقف التوسع الاستيطاني ومنعهم في
المستوطنين وضمان محاسبه الجنات البيان
الاوروبيه اكد على وجوب الحفاظ على الوضع
الراهن للاماكن المقدسه بما يتماشى مع
التفاهمات السابقه واضاف انه يجب ان تكون
العمليات العسكريه متناسبه ومتوافقه مع
القانون الدولي الانساني واشار البيان
الاوروبي الى ان الوضع الانسانيه في قطاع
غزه يتطلب مزيدا من تخفيف القيود كما طالب
البيان جميع الاطراف بالالتزام باتفاقيات
العقبه بحسن نيه مؤكده على استعاده الافق
السياسي نحو حل الدولتين ضمن اتفاق تفاوضى
يوفر فرصه للامن والسلام للجميع
من جهته قال فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش يتابع تطورات في جنين وحواره
ويشعر بقلق عميق تجاه تزايد عدد ضحايا
العنف في الضفه الغربيه المحتله حق اضاف
ان الامين العام يدعو الى محاسبه جميع
مرتكب اعمال العنف غير المشروع
يعرب الامير العام عن قلقه العميق من
تزايد عدد المدنيين بمنفهم النساء
والاطفال الذين وقعوا ضحايا للعنف في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله بما في ذلك في
حواره وهو يتابع اخر التطورات التي حدثت
في جنين ويحث الامين العام جميع الاطراف
المعنيه على اتخاذ خطوات فوريه لتخفيف
التوتر ويدعو الى محاسبه جميع مرتكبي
اعمال العنف
كما اعرب منسق الامم المتحده الخاص لعمليه
السلامه في الشرق الاوسط
عن انزعاجه الشديد ما سماه استمرار العنف
معربا عن فزعه من هجمات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين وشدد على
ضروره حمايه جميع المدنيين ووقف دائره
العنف على الفور